name is
Yogananda uh this opportunity this all
takes to pay the thanks to allmighty
Allah for today peace to humanity has
been seated through Dr Zakir
[Applause]
[Music]
n peace to humanity for the Hindu Muslim
Unity so thanks very much for very great
effort he has taken by going through all
the Vos and other things da big task he
has done but still more is the another
part of in Hinduism that is he has
touched the matter of vanta there is
sidhanta is another one is there that
also if he concentrate still more he can
give very good evidences and it will be
very good father peace to humanity for
the future okay thank you very much
thanks
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm thankful to the brother's
comment may Allah accept our effort and
I'm aware brother there are many things
more we can talk normally my talk is for
1 hour to 1 hour 15 minutes today I
requested brother Zak speak for 1 and a
half and I spoke for 1 hour 40
minutes and I'm aware that whatever we
do whatever we do research it's just a
drop in the ocean and for more
information you can refer to my
cassettes on concept of God in major
religions Muhammad sallah the major
world the scriptures and the many books
I written on these topics as well on
Hinduism inshallah if a person goes
through them they'll get more knowledge
on the similarities on Hinduism and
Islam
hope